- I know titi and tita are
auntie and aunt, well, auntie.
Titi is auntie, that's all I know.
(upbeat piano music)
- Tae lang naman ako sa'yo eh?
- Tae lang naman ako sa'yo eh!
- Tae lang naman ako sa'yo eh.
- I want to say put on gina,
(laughing)
but I feel like that sounds dirty.
- Putangina
- Somebody said to somebody to eat shit.
- Putangeena
- Pinapahirapan mo ako.
- Pina, wow.
- Pina pie ree--
- That's a long word.
- Pina pirate mo apple.
- Pinapahirapan mo ako.
- Kailangan pa bang sagutin 'yan?
- Mga inutil hindi tayo mamamasyal.
- Inutil
- Mga inutil, exclamation point.
- Mga inutil.
- You're worthless, you're
worth nothing to me.
- Para kayong mga--
- Para kayong mga birheng--
- Para kayong (fart noise)
- Para kayong mga birheng naniniwala
sa pag-ibig ng isang puta.
- I know that last one.
- Baka sinasabi mo lang'yan,
- Kasi lasing na ako,
- At saka lasing ka na rin.
- What does it mean?
- [mustache] Let's get it on!
- [lady] I was gonna say
let's go for a drink,
let's go for a drink tonight.
(laughing)
- That sounds like a Drake song.
- like a Drake song (laughing).